je pense que c'est ce que vous voulez
parler c'est ça qui vous a fait passer
de l'autre côté je comprends pas comment
on est passé de lentilles vague
sentiment ce qui est tout à fait audible
intellectuellement à ses outrances qui
manifestement n'ont plus rien à voir
avec cette causerait alors florian bague
nettement jeudi à yann moix que je vous
savez moi je suis invalide depuis
quarante deux semaines je ne vous disait
que ça fait quarante deux ans vous êtes
en manif
je manifeste quarante deux semaines sur
ce sujet large sur la restriction de
liberté sur le pas de sa guitare ce sont
des manifestations qui se passe
extraordinairement bien je dire et avec
un public extrêmement dit les gens qu'il
ya eu des dérives lorient on a vu des
dés et pancartes voilà anticipe
les dirigeants ce qu'il faut pas trop
regardé bfmtv parce que bfmtv fait
volontairement un amalgame ils vont
trouver une personne même dans une manif
qui n'a rien à voir avec la nôtre ils la
passent en boucle et vous dise et ça ça
témoigne de 100000 manifesto ça
s'appelle un amalgame et c'est une
technique de communication qui
d'ailleurs lancé par le gouvernement ce
qu'on comprend il a envie de discréditer
le mouvement ne s'est pas du tout et les
personnes qui sont dans les
manifestations peuvent vous le dire ce
que nous voyons chaque samedi est ce
qu'on va encore voir samedi prochain où
nous partons du champ-de-mars d'ailleurs
l'après midi à 14 heures et je je je
veux simplement me défendre moi
l'honneur de ces manifestants qui sont
des gens il faut parler il faut venir
yann moix que j'aimerais que vous veniez
j'ai vu mais monsieur fenech a appelé
les caissons l'aria vélib régnante
il faut
hélas le chat potté est ce que vos
manifestants seraient d'accord pour
signer une décharge à des sports du fait
qu'ils accepteraient de ne pas
bénéficier des soins intensifs en car
que c'est que le coc vide nommé
de société
parce que si vous rentrez dans ce genre
de société on va demander à bressanone
en obésité morbide de signer aussi des
décharges qu'elles ne font pas un régime
va demander à des gens diabète je
sais aussi que jusqu'ici à présent ont
battu dans les principes et je vous
demande de rester sur cette position
parce que vous mettez le doigt dans un
engrenage à mon avis est extrêmement
dangereux pour répondre à la première
question si tu es la meilleure qu'est ce
qu'on devrait faire mais on devrait
faire ce qu'on fait des pays qui se sont
pas exciter comme on le fait depuis 18
mois allez à vous balader au japon allez
vous balader en suède sont des pays qui
ont des meilleurs résultats que nous à
tout point de vue un mortalité comme
économie comme tout est superbe défense
des libertés ils se sont pas excité
depuis 18 mois sur cette affaire les
différents horizons ami déconfinement
ils n'ont pas fermé comme ça alors à
restaurants ils n'ont pas détruit leur
jeunesse ils ont traité une maladie
sereinement qui n'est pas la peste noire
donc moi je pense que au bout d'un
moment au delà du pass sanitaires il
faut qu'on revienne sur terre on est en
crise de nerfs gravissant leur fait
payer trop tôt des douleurs queen sera
philippe oh non on va dire un acte et si
la majorité du pays avait été contre le
passé contre la vaccination est ce que
vous auriez pas été pour est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas toujours
[Rires]
ce que vous dites on peut le vérifier
parce que moi j'ai lancé une pétition
contre le passé ni terre en novembre
dernier et toujours sur le site des
patriotes à un moment où dans les
sondages les gens étaient contre le pass
sanitaires voyez donc votre argument ne
tient pas je gère un site extrêmement
clair et la liberté en fait partie et il
n'y a pas que la liberté c'est une
question de dignité c'est une question
d'égalité fondamentale entre les
citoyens on voit bien ce soir c'est ça
témoigne nous c'est pas grave on s'en
fiche d'être dehors
des gens qui perdent leur boulot il ya
des gens qui n'ont plus aucun droit il
ya des gens qui vivent extrêmement mal
et qui sont dans une difficulté je peux
vous dire psychiatriques psychologiques
sociales qui est juste indigne d'un pays
comme la france et je comprends pas que
le conseil constitué à le conseil d'état
et les parlementaires aient laissé
passer toute cette horreur je vous le
dis clairement je trouve que c'est
vraiment indigne de l'alors